saran-wrap adele is a rescue pilot he
makes a living from other people who
were in trouble
climbers who have misjudged the dangers
of the Himalayas
Surendra and his colleagues are the
first crew in the pool who can retrieve
injured people with a rescue line known
as the long line a skill which they
learn from the Swiss in 2012
Paolina August I was there for long line
training and multiplied there is much
more you know systematic in Switzerland
and we are picking up we are trying to
get in the Swiss format of doing rescues
I'm going for further training for
advanced training that I have been I
have not been doing the long line rescue
here in Nepal so after I go training in
Switzerland I probably come here and do
longline rescue during the peak season
for mountain climbing surrender and his
team take off on rescue operations five
or six times a day they reach altitudes
of up to five and a half thousand metres
today the men are going on a training
flight to practice search-and-rescue
after 30 minutes in the air Surrender
discovers the man they need to rescue
but he can't land the Eurocopter here
the ground is too steep three kilometres
away they managed to land the rescue
rope is fastened to the helicopter and
used to lower one of the mountain
rescuers down to the casual team you
have a good chance the rescue yep only
the M word my concern is about the
weather you can see now if the moving is
the fog is moving so faster so before
that do we need to get him up from there
but in reality assistance usually
arrives too late the region of Mount
Everest is the highest adventure
playground in the world 8,848 meters
high to date more than 4,000
thrill-seekers have managed to climb the
highest mountain in the world climbing
Everest costs about 50,000 euros this
goes from the pools government and the
organisers for the climb even if you
don't reach the summit the last disaster
happened on April 18th 2014 at Khumbu
Icefall Sherpas wanted to build a bridge
over the deep ice crevices for the
climbers just as an avalanche was
triggered 16 Sherpas lost their lives
the accident sent shockwaves through
Nepal the many tragedies that occur on
Mount Everest a witnessed firsthand by
the communities and the valley of
Katmandu a lot of Sherpa families live
here including Anne Posey with her son
her husband was a Sherpa who led
foreigners up to the summit the
Avalanche on April 18th claimed his life
his widow and son found refuge in a
small room at her brother's house the
death of my husband changed my whole
life I just need to see how my baby and
I can get through it
my best option is to emigrate the young
widow received the equivalent of 9,000
euros in compensation almost two years
wages from the Nepalese government Mount
Everest a blessing and a curse more than
nine thousand Sherpas and their families
make their living as porters and guides
since the summit was first reached in
1953 they've been helping the mountain
climbers find their way as well as
carrying equipment food and oxygen
cylinders they are well paid for this
job but they're poorly insured in
Katmandu we meet the Sherpa Pam Luang
shrew one of the most experienced
mountain climbers in the pool he
survived the catastrophe on April 18th
but one of his friends lost his life he
and his friends widow commemorate the
victims in the large Serpa temple after
the catastrophe we couldn't just keep on
climbing
we brought the bodies to the families
and then we went on strike it was the
first time the Sherpas had gone on
strike we demanded higher life insurance
and a professional Mountain Rescue
Service that's exactly why Surendra
steamer training today they want to be
as efficient as their colleagues in
Switzerland one of them is being lowered
down to the casualty on the rescue rope
on the ground
the man is tied securely to a rescue net
with the rescuer safely fastened to the
rope the pilot flies into the valley a
distance of 10 kilometres at an altitude
of 200 metres until they reach a
hospital
all too often surrender and his men are
cooled out too late because payment
hasn't been clarified travel agencies
and insurance companies in Nepal prefer
to avoid the expenses for rescue flights
sir and Roberto wants to change that
along with other experts he wants to
establish a mountain rescue service in
the pool based on the Swiss model after
a 10 hour working day the pilot returns
to his wife and daughter in their little
house on the edge of town since I'm so
proud of him
we need is with someone I just I feel
very proud that's the most happiest
moment for me the rescue pilots like to
pray to the gods
every time they return home unharmed and
of course they pray for the victims